do you have a celebrity crush lots of
celebrity crush who's like the one so
there's this light-skinned black girl
who was in Saved by the Bell a new class
she's still in actors now her dad is
married to Beyonce his mom so I don't
you got to put all the math together and
find her because I don't even remember
her name
she's so obscure but she's hot what's up
everybody I'm Krista Stefano aka Krissy
hazelnut spread and this is live from
the limo stupid questions
it is standup month I am with James
Davis his special airs tonight it's
called live from the town you're gonna
like it you're gonna love it
let's get naked what would you say your
weirdest recurring nightmare or dream I
have this dream that I'm still in
college okay and that there's a class
that I just have not been showing up to
and it's it haunts me like yo you're
failing this class you just don't go
maybe I have unfinished business or
something without you graduate college
absolutely not I know in the back of the
limo with our specials yeah yeah yeah
take that uh yeah wishing money listen
if you know me you know that I like fun
facts so what is a fun fact about your
special that people need to know
so one not that high show too high off
my ass and show two is what most people
are gonna be seeing it's a mix oh
there's gonna be shots where I'm like oh
I'm locked in and then yeah there's a
cutaway it's like look at the last did
your mom like you're special my mom was
at my special so you don't mind
performing in front of your parents
actually no I don't I don't mind you
don't feel like they've seen me at my
worst they know all my secrets there's
nothing I can do to really embarrass
myself in front of them cuz I mean they
clean to my poop
my mom has picked me up from a party
where I was drunk right you know like is
that where she cleaned up your poop
here we go if your life was a cocktail
what would actually no you know what
let's be honest if your life was a type
of weed what would it be
let's just be real what kind of weed is
your life a indica dominant hybrid okay
this gracious I hate how specific that
is it listed you're having a problem and
America knows now a strand I would just
say green crack I just like the name
green yeah here's the thing green I'm
making money crack that's like my jokes
they're addictive yeah they have you
coming back I need more of that James
stand-up comedy there you go I don't
know what you don't put the crack there
no no not but yeah well we've already
established weed is my drug now that is
something I don't want my mom I was
stupid questions limo dish and stand up
month edition it's kind of like a new
kind of deal that we have this month you
still get a stupid gift okay okay now
it's January we're in New York you're
from LA you like hats so I thought why
not get you a New York hat that does
look like the colors of a certain New
York team but it is not we just bought
it at a 99-cent store and it's for you
and I know your swag doubt so that I
figured is it is the Hat for you it
reminds me of the beanies that Eddie
Murphy in Arsenio Hall were wearing and
coming to America when they got to New
York there you go now you got something
new to masturbate until perfect genius
[Music]
you